hello there I'm Edmund Tran and I'm
joined by Luke Lancaster from cnet.com
hi we've both seen x-men apocalypse and
we're here to give you some of our
spoiler free or spoiler light
impressions of the film just coming out
in America very soon so first of all
what do you think Luke I feel like this
is going to split fans right down them
yeah like hey yeah there's a lot in the
movie that's great yeah there's a lot of
really good bits yeah and I think
there's a lot of bits that would have
been really good if this came out 10
years ago yeah that's right I'm kind of
feeling the same way there were lots of
really cool scenes and moments and
character bits then at the same time
there's a lot of dialogue really
unnecessary scenes I felt also some
quite bad action beats as well oh yeah
yeah especially the last five I thought
it was really snappy yeah that's right
that's right I'm telling you with you
there so that's gonna break it down will
kind of go through the setup conceit
first yeah
apocalypse yeah apocalypse is like the
original mute yeah right so he's back in
ancient Egypt kind of thing yeah which
was the teaser from the end of Days of
Future Passed right and he's back
siphoning and kind of mutant power yes
and he wants to take over the world
because he's a villain in comic book
movie yeah what did you think about this
setup for the film I thought it was
really convoluted the film spent a lot
of time sitting up in the eventual final
battle of apocalyptic things over yeah
like it was a long movie to begin with
two and a half hours yeah and I think
close to the first half-hour
it was just like different introductory
scenes for all these new characters
that's right and it really kind of just
just get to it
yeah exactly I mean this this is
essentially another soft reboot
yeah series reintroducing a lot of
cactus we have seen before
but because of retconning in the series
we're starting fresh again so what do
you think of Apocalypse himself as a
villain I love Oscar Isaac I do but
meter do we really need another giant
purple dude you know yeah he was so
forgettable and I wanted him to be
better than he was and it's such a shame
because Oscar Isaac is such a great in
sort of flexible active - in this
not a great role for him but how about
some of the new cast members so let's go
through them all like there's a cyclops
looks like clubs I guess he was one who
had like the closest traditional origin
story in the movie but I don't know he
was just he's just Cyclops and no one
like a cyclops no one like Cyclops in
fact like so the film does spend a
little bit of time with Cyclops and his
art in the story which in which you feel
some sympathy for sort of his yeah his
character and then immediately he just
over the course of a day it turns into a
huge he did have some cool power moments
though I kind of joined his sort of
show-off ability yeah it seemed like he
actually had the concussive force like
this is the nerdiest thing but the
concussive force lasers you instead of
like the heat lasers but their punches
they don't like fire being that's right
yeah yeah
okay how about Eugene Gregg she was my
favorite of the new car oh really okay
well that's I really like so if you turn
on yeah I thought she had the most to do
with all the new character yeah and you
know I'm not seem to know that's verging
into spoiler territory but I really
liked her I think more than anyone else
okay well we were down there storm I
really loved the new storm he was great
yeah I didn't like Halle Berry as Dom at
all
and this new storm with mohawk and
everything I felt like and genuine it
did feel like stuff yeah it felt like
storm unfortunately she didn't get a lot
of screen time I've had to some of the
others but yeah that felt like a common
issue through the movie that like so
many cool characters and none of them
really got enough screen time to shine
yeah I mean the difference between sort
of apocalypse and Civil War is that you
know we've spent a lot of time at the
Civil War the same actors that
reintroducing a whole bunch of new
people the same kind of a man yeah makes
a problem but you can have Edmund in a
movie for five minutes because he's had
an entire feature already that's right
but you can't as effectively sell me on
storm having a in a movie for five
minutes as well yeah Psylocke again I
liked Olivia - I love ya but she looks
great as Cylons even about your perfect
she is but again she didn't have
anything you didn't having much to do
what do you think of her powers
I thought visually they were pretty cool
um and I've seen some behind the same
cell phone ring a lot like Olivia Munn
doing a lot
fight training yeah which was really
cool but it's that one shot that's in
the trailer that's mine right her
splitting of the car down yeah at all
that's basically her highlights yeah but
she really isn't giving enough enough
time to shine Nightcrawler I call is
another one I really liked was like I
love the Ellen coming yes
the original Michael yeah but he was
really cool yeah it was he was another
perfect night but it was not crawler we
kind of likes a timid little guy who had
really great vamps he was like laughing
all over the place
I really enjoyed they touched on the
kind of religious aspect of the
character yes well but they didn't make
it a whole thing yeah was yeah really
really well died and I think he worked
quite well as he younger yeah and as
well he worked as part of the outsider
coming into the group they all sort of
world but him most definitely yeah angel
not a fan of angel no I never liked him
as a character did he do anything apart
from like the one body horror scene
which in it just always you know yeah
part of that Jubilee everyone was really
waiting for a lot of Jubilee given those
teasers in the trailers I mean she
turned up and she was you know 2002 yeah
she looks good and she did get to spend
some time yes the core crew yeah which
is nice but if you were expecting like
serious Jubilee time you may have
disappointed she's definitely Jubilee so
returning characters obviously we've
spent some time with Fassbender and
McAvoy as savior and Magneto
as well as Jennifer Lawrence as mistake
mystique which thing look just to lead
off McAvoy does not look good bald who
does not have the same gravitas and
Patrick Stewart I mean no few people do
but I think the contrivance of how he
becomes bald was a bit much as well yeah
he was fine he had a weird kind of
relationship subplot with Rose Byrne who
was also back and has more on the [ __ ]
yeah but it's like first class on Days
of Future past Fassbender stealing shot
whenever years pretty definitely
definitely in McAvoy it plays that
really like the Playboy
Xavier well yeah that even though
they're trying to transition him I'm not
sure how it's successful I found that
yeah I mean quite deliberately with very
explicit nods to Magneto and xavius
dialogue
movies yes that's wrong but yeah I agree
with you I think he's gonna struggle to
be the leader yeah especially because he
looks the same age yeah that's right
mystique Raven do you like Jennifer
Lawrence as a mistake because I am NOT
digging it no I feel like she gave up on
the character before Days of Future past
and it was just a bit phoned in yeah and
so same deal in this film you I mean all
credit to her she's a she's a fantastic
actor yeah but same deal here she just I
don't think she cares okay Beast
anything to say about Beast it was even
in a movie he did some no feed bits of
these things ate he was fine
finally Quicksilver okay so as good as
Evan Peters is as Quicksilver and he's
better in this than he was in Days of
Future past I thought it was such a
sequel lightest thing where because he
was popular in a small role in Days of
Future past he has a massively expanded
role in this one yeah and he did carry
it quite well yeah but a lot of the
let's do Quicksilver action sequences
because people like those yes that was I
think a bit much here because the
original was so hard to top yeah that's
right I mean Quicksilver like he is a
good portrayal of the character than the
model cinema various version and he
brought some of the sort of the lighter
moments to the film you know exactly
what to expect yeah Quicksilver on his
phone he probably had the best character
moments that's right the thing I feel
like there was a bit of uneven tone in
the film like oscillating between very
serious moment and comedy but he
straddled that better than anyone else
and finally if you've been sort of
watching the trailers you know that
there may or may not be a cameo so is
just a turn-off now if you don't want
any spoilers moment yeah so if you
haven't seen any of the trailers maybe
switch the video off now bit if you you
know if you have been haven't been
living under a rock then you know that's
someone or something maybe have a
presence in the film what do you think
about that the way okay I'll be very
careful in my language here the actual
setup for that I thought was
so contrived yeah like the level of
coincidence that would have had to
happen for things to happen the way they
did but the characters actual appearance
I really liked the fact that it was
spot-on
mmm like that was the perfect outfit
yeah no I completely agree really good
sort of nods to like the comic and
things surrounding that that's a choice
let's say that characters exit is my
favorite shot in the entire movie yeah
no I agree yeah we both had a really
good laugh in the cinema overall do you
think x-men fans would enjoy this one
I think they really will because there
was so much fanservice packing there
like I I was entertained but I had
issues yeah I think it's a see once
movie not a one that's gonna hold up to
repeat viewings like yeah x-men 1 or
x-men 2
yeah I definitely think like going
through it the moments that wowed me
were enough to make me to enjoy it yeah
not think it was a great film but you
know feel good about seeing it I think
the the climactic battle kind of
disappointed me and a lot of respects in
terms of how their immense power is to
be used it it was nothing new either
like you've seen that fight scene before
yeah not not that exact fighting but the
way it's been staged you've seen that
kind of thing before yeah
I also need to mention that coming
straight off the back of Civil War I was
actually quite shocked at how much
violence is actually in the x-men series
yeah I completely forgot about that the
opening kind of action sequence yes that
was really gory it was really gory not
even that yeah a lot of people died in
this film a lot yeah okay and finally
this credit scene there is one yes what
did you think about it and how
significant is it compared to the other
ones that the character they are teasing
is awesome yeah if that's what they're
going on to do yeah but I've seen so
many conflicting reports about what the
next x-men movies are the hearts right
that I'm not sure okay so sum up your
thoughts on x-men in like five ten words
it is a classic comic book movie but I
don't think that's enough anymore
that's a really good summary I don't do
any better are you gonna try if you like
anime you may enjoy this oh wow that's
that's good okay cool so x-men
apocalypse is out officially in the UK
and Australia on the may 18th and 19th
and it will be in cinemas in the US on
May 27th I believe mm-hmm and if you're
after a full written review of x-men
apocalypse you could buy one on
gamespot.com